à tout âge à faire société c'est le
thème de la semaine bleue qui débute
aujourd'hui bonjour charles barkley
bonjour vous êtes le président de la
fédération des clubs de 3e âge de
martinique et vous avez certainement
remarqué qu'on parle de plus en plus de
ce teaser économie la prise en charge
des personnes âgées les politiques qui
en découlent
c'est un dossier qui avance dans
d'autres il selon vous oui il faudrait
déjà définir exactement ce que l'on
entend par là s'il veut économie ce
concept tout à fait nouveau une
expression au cul des spas française
d'ailleurs donc il vient qui vient
d'ailleurs et qui est que que conflit
data louis denoit que l'on importé et
qu'on donne à importer ici alors bon la
silver economy com se l'était dit tout à
l'heure ce serait bon les une économie
au service des seniors alors il faut
s'interroger sur aussi la capacité mais
le ddc n'y en a consommé cette bougie
sur leur pouvoir d'achat est ce qu'elle
est innée sauvegarder est-ce qu'il est
amplifié ce n'est pas un concept il ya
une loi d'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement de la population
oui alors cette l'autonomie découle de
sa wii cette sécheresse ironique en
disant ça oui c'est vrai cette loi fait
référence aux à la silver economy bon
mais vous savez qu'un effet de mode nous
n'allons pas développé l'origine de
cette expression dans la loi
d'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement de la population mais il
faut pas se faire d'illusions bon parce
que qu'attendent les aînés les aînés bon
ont des besoins que nous que l'on
connaît on n'a pas attendu que là s'il
veut économies pour appréhender ses
besoins cccc d'une part une augmentation
de leur pouvoir d'achat c'est des
actions en termes de création de
structures d'accueil pour les personnes
dépendantes parce que de la santé plus
de plus en plus les personnes les
dépendante vont en institution est là
l'âge moyen ses 92 en institution donc
les personnes restent à domicile donc de
là la réponse apportée à tout ça c'est
de favoriser le maintien à domicile et
permettent justement cette vie à
domicile par une adaptation de l'habitat
donc un certain nombre de deux réponses
appropriées
vous avez fait allusion à ce pouvoir
d'achat de nos seniors
lorsqu'on entend par exemple dans le
journal tout à l'heure avec l'autre
gratien de la chambre régionale des
comptes qui préconise une augmentation
de 15 % des impôts locaux
là vous vous révoltez on attaque
directement ce pouvoir d'achat notamment
des seniors
absolument actuellement il ya il y a de
quoi se révolter parce que le set
la chambre régionale des comptes faits
certaines préconisations ces
collectivités mais l'un il faut que les
communes aussi à sur le métier du
pouvoir d'achat de de l'heure
de leurs concitoyens lorsque dans une
année dernière une je ne veux pas la
citer une grande commune du sud décidé
le doublement de la taxe d'habitation
bon eh bien c'est ça des conséquences
énormes importante surtout lorsque l'on
sait que les bases sur lesquelles sont
appliquées ces taux sont déjà eux-mêmes
élevé et puis il ya un autre via notre
kop à d'autres problèmes qu'il se pose
lorsque vous êtes en activité vous avez
la chance d'avoir une maison une
habitation bien selon le lieu vous
habitez bon les bases qui sont fixées
par les temps ce sera la commune bon
tiennent compte les bases tiennent
compte de certains nombre de choses mais
une fois que vous êtes à la retraite vos
ressources ont diminué pas de pauvres de
plus de 50%
donc comment pouvez vous continuer à
assumer assumer le paiement de ses
impôts
surtout lorsqu'il augmente de façon à
retirer demain aussi elle considère vous
demander une intervention au niveau de
l'état des instances locales qu'est ce
que vous voulez c'est une intervention
au niveau des instances locales
c'est-à-dire que les communes prennent
conscience au niveau dans leur politique
de fiscale la fiscalité locale et le
prennent conscience de la de la
situation des aînés de jouer lorsqu'on
parle de silver economy charlebois créé
c'est parce qu'on considère qu'il ya une
niche ya un potentiel bien la ja isle à
réservoir il ya quelque chose à faire
pour faire faire du business comme on
dit c'est la haute s'élance et ont peur
d'annoncer à mon sens et ont peur parce
que ils se vendent l'aller on a toujours
brand fait personnellement je considère
que le les personnes âgées ne doivent
pas constituer un fonds de commerce pour
qui que ce soit au départ on a tout faux
lorsqu'on veut faire du business ce
prétexte il faut c'est ce dont ont
besoin les personnages et ce sont ces
blancs surtout ce sont des penseurs
humaines des réponses humaines des
transits et la suite raccompagné de la
considération de la reconnaissance
l'inclusion sociale et c'est un bon mais
aujourd'hui les personnes j'ai pu nous
pas ne sont pas des consommateurs
potentiels importants surtout dans une
autre petit territoire et à l'exécuter
du territoire et puis on s'est compris
que l'importance du nombre de
bénéficiaires d'allocations du régime
général qui sont au niveau du minimum
vieillesse ou parfois en dessous du
minimum vieillesse
donc comment pouvez vous en faire des
consommateurs de regarder autre chose
charles barkley est ce que vous direz
que sur le plan fiscal le troisième âge
et seniors on peut parler de racket
vis-à-vis d'eux pourrait on pourrait
utiliser le mot pour utiliser le mot
dans la mesure où faisons une
comparaison lorsque la baguette
augmentent de 5 ou 10 ans thing vous
estimez que c'est trop cher
vous achetez moins deux baguettes vous
n'achetez pas ce qu'on produit etc
tandis que lorsque l'afp le on a
augmenté les impôts on a doublé une taxe
d'habitation now doubler les impôts
comme cela va se faire au diamant
puisque vous venez d'annoncer la
nouvelle
si vous quand vous ne pouvez pas payer
et bien le percepteur fait une retenue
immédiatement sur votre pension donc
vous êtes
contraire donc sauf à obtenir des délais
mais il faut de toute façon il faudra
payer
avec quelles ressources donc on diminue
votre pouvoir d'achat donc votre
capacité à relancer la consommation et
c'est l'économie générale qui a pendant
qu'il qui en souffre
chaque barque et ces croix un senior
aujourd'hui vous savez lorsqu'on regarde
les différents organismes qui parle de
silver economy les les organismes
publics qui qui chiffre qui analyse etc
on sait pas ce que c'est un senior ça
commence à 45 ans ça commence à 49 ans
ça commence à 50 ans soit ans et c'est
qu'ici il ya une difficulté de dans la
définition des seniors pour certains de
les seniors ce sont des gens de 50 ans
et plus s'est peut-être que michel
rocard à l'époque avait défini les
seniors comme étant des gens d'à partir
de 50 ans bon dans la loi sur le
vieillissement de la population où il
est fait référence à la soulever
économie on parle des seniors du grand
âge c'est-à-dire des gens de plus de 75
ans 81 81 ans donc ya pas une définition
précise de cela mais ce qui serait
intéressant je pensais ça répond à un
besoin là dessus c'est une une
connaissance précise de la population
des personnages et des retraités
il faut une enquête pour définir le
profil
quels sont les pour retraités du régime
général de des retraités du régime d de
l'état des retraités du régime de la
fonction publique territoriale fonction
publique hospitalière et c'est des
régimes spéciaux
vous avez tout un outil simple ce n'est
pas une population homogène donc il y à
des niveaux de culture différente des
conditions d'existence différente des
revenus différents donc c'est à partir
de 7,7 cette étude oui ça lisette et
toute cette analyse qu'on pouvoir
définir des cibles des cibles d'action
qui sera trop cher jamais en clé il faut
être clair être senior peut être dans
certains quartiers résidentiels de fort
de france est pas la même chose qu'être
seniors dans la campagne belge pavillon
du ca tescou d'ailleurs exactement parce
que les besoins ne sont pas les mêmes et
on n'a pas tous les seniors ne sont pas
ne sont pas identiques il n'ya pas
d'homogénéité dans cette définition de
seniors faire société
vous dites que c'est important parce que
ça permet de d'entourer nos aînés c'est
ça qui est le plus important s'il faut
retenir quelque chose de cette semaine
bleue qui débute aujourd'hui
oui ce c'est ça c'est important c'est à
dire faire société pour se prouver pour
les aînés c'est être être en lien créé
du lien cueillait du lien social pour
que des personnes soient entourées
participent à la vie sociale à la vie
citoyenne qu'elle ne se sente pas exclu
qu'elles répondent elles ont bien besoin
d'utilité d'utilité sociale et elle joue
son rôle
aujourd'hui on dit que ce sont les
parents les grands parents qui sont les
premiers les premiers ce qui assure le
premier service d'accueil de la petite
enfance et c'est vrai si c'est vrai donc
c'est une action économique qui déparent
finances qui n'est pas finançable qui
n'est pas y'a pas des changes monétaires
mais ça il ya une fonction économique
non ce sont ces toutes ces actions là
qu'il faut reconnaître il ya un besoin
de reconnaissance et aussi a besoin
d'affection
vous savez le construire aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il faut ce cap nau exemple on
écoute on les doléances des personnes à
travers les associations c'est je dirais
qu il faut construire de nouvelles de
nouvelles solidarités qui ne soit pas
uniquement basée sur une route
distribution des aides sociales aide
financière mais qui ait de nouvelles
solidarités qui prennent leur soucieux
socle de valeurs
deux d'entre elles de partage de
fraternité de solidarité ça c'est le
plus important
merci d'avoir été avec nos charlesbourg
qu'ils ont on retiendra cette idée plus
de solidarité chandhok et président de
la fédération des clubs de 3e âge de
martigues merci d'arrêter ce matin dans
son caddie